Ankunft der Außenministerin in Juda
Saudi-Arabien es ist ihr Antrittsbesuch
in der Golfregion das Königreich ist ein
wichtiger Handelspartner seit dem
Embargo gegen Russland importiert
Deutschland mehr Erdöl aus dem Golfstaat
auch grüner Wasserstoff für die deutsche
Energiewende soll künftig von hier
kommen
Rückblick September letzten Jahres
händeschüttel mit einem skrupellosen
Diktator Bundeskanzler Scholz reißt zum
saudischen Kronprinzen Mohammed bin
Salman im Vordergrund die
Wirtschaftsinteressen trotz massiver
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
Außenministerin baerbock hat sich
vorgenommen dieses heikle Thema bei
ihrem Treffen mit Außenminister Prinz
Faisal bin Farhan anzusprechen
Saudi-Arabien ist nach dem Iran das Land
mit den meisten Hinrichtungen
Meinungsfreiheit existiert hier nicht
und sogar gab es auch keine gemeinsame
Pressekonferenz mit dem Gastgeber die
deutsche Außenministerin tritt allein
vor die Journalisten doch sie äußert
kaum Kritik dafür viel Lob für das
Engagement bei der Lösung des Konflikts
im Sudan ich bin Saudi-Arabien für diese
Evakuierung von vielen Bürgern und zwar
Bürgern der ganzen Welt sehr dankbar die
Golfstaaten spielen eine immer
wichtigere Rolle bei der diplomatischen
Vermittlung regionaler Krisen doch auch
geopolitisch gewinnen Sie einen Einfluss
Länder wie Saudi Arabien streben danach
an der Seite von Russland und China ein
politisches Gegengewicht zum Westen
aufzubauen
wir sprechen ist uns aus Kiel
zugeschaltet stellvertretender CDU CSU
Fraktionschef und Außenpolitiker guten
Morgen voll
moin vor der Kieler Förde wie bewerten
sie den Besuch von Außenministerin
werbock in Saudi Arabien ja ist ein
dringend notwendiger Besucher auf denen
glaube ich wir alle lange gewartet haben
Saudi-Arabien ist ebenso wie Ägypten in
der Region ein langjähriger
verlässlicher Partner Deutschlands ein
strategischer Partner nicht nur
wirtschaftlich von dem Interesse sondern
auch für die Sicherheitsstruktur der
dortigen Region von großer Bedeutung und
die hat natürlich für uns für Europa
wieder eine große Bedeutung weil wir
nicht nur energiepolitisch abhängig sind
sondern weil eine der wichtigsten
Handelsrouten sich durch das Rote Meer
und den so ist Kanal bewegt aus Asien
hier nach Europa also Frau bärbock hatte
viel aufzuholen und ich denke wenn ich
das jetzt höre und sehe dass Sie auf dem
richtigen Weg ist wir dürfen in diesen
Ländern nicht mit dem erhobenen
Zeigefinger auftreten sondern müssen Sie
als Partner sehen natürlich müssen und
sollen wir auf Menschenrechtssituation
hinweisen aber Außenpolitik ist vor
allen Dingen
Interessenpolitik Deutschlands und
Europas und ich hoffe dass die
Ministerin das deutlicher erkennt als
bisher nun ja sie hat ja eigentlich
beides angesprochen in Saudi-Arabien zum
einen geopolitische Interessen deutlich
gemacht und auf der anderen Seite auch
Menschenrechtsfragen angesprochen also
ist das dann der Kurs muss man beides
tun ja man muss beides tun aber man muss
sich auch immer darüber im Klaren sein
dass wir hier aus Deutschland glaube ich
nicht diejenigen sind die als Oberlehrer
auftreten sollten Saudi-Arabien
reformiert sich in einem atemberaubenden
Tempo oder die Gesellschaft ändert sich
und gerade der jetzige Kronprinz hat ja
dass die Gleichberechtigung von Frauen
angeht also ein irres Tempo jetzt
vorgegeben das geht in diesem Land sehr
schnell wir dürfen es nur nicht mit
unseren Maßstäben vergleichen deswegen
ist es richtig
auf vieles hinzuweisen es gibt
Todesurteile das verurteilen wir
weltweit auch dort aber vor allen Dingen
brauchen wir das Land als Partner
wirtschaftlich und politisch weil sie
gerade den Kronprinzen angesprochen
haben alle Indizien sprechen ja dafür
dass der saudische Journalisten vom
saudischen Geheimdienst ermordet wurde
weil er eben den saudischen Kronprinzen
bin Salman kritisierte darum die Frage
weil das ja eben viele interessiert wo
ist die Grenze bei der sie dann sagen
bis hierhin und nicht weiter oder gibt's
diese Grenze nicht mehr
na ja wir haben das ja damals gemeinsam
mit westlichen Partnern auf die
Vereinigten Staaten verurteilt das sind
dann wenn sie das verurteilen
wir können deutsche Außenpolitik nicht
jahrzehntelang durch so einen Vorfall
leben lassen das muss man ganz nüchtern
erkennen im übrigen hat der grundprinz
selber dementiert dass er dafür
verantwortlich sei und diese Erklärung
muss man zur Kenntnis nehmen
wir können unsere Interessen in der
Region nicht nur gegenüber diesem Land
sondern in der gesamten Region
nicht ständig mit Sanktionspolitik
versuchen betreiben zu wollen das ist
ein verkehrter Ansatz sie müssen sehen
dass vorhin ist das schon angesprochen
worden es gibt eine Annäherung zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Iran die wird
mittlerweile von China vermittelt das
heißt der Westen insgesamt die USA aber
auch Europa verlieren dort an Bedeutung
die Außenministerin hat sich heute über
Saudi Arabien bedankt das ist eine
konstruktive Rolle im Sudan ja und
vielleicht wahrgenommen hat wir spielen
dort fast keine Rolle mehr und deswegen
müssen wir zu unseren Interessen
zurückkommen und die nüchtern und
sachlich wahrnehmen nun gibt es eine
neue Welt seit dem Ukraine Krieg das
Zauberwort heißt da Diversifizierung an
man darf sich nicht nur von einer Seite
abhängig machen wenn man jetzt mal auf
die Demokratie Weltkarte schaut auf
dieser Welt gibt es laut Demokratie
Index nur 23 vollständige Demokratie was
bedeutet das dann für so heißt es ja von
der Bundesregierung Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik
ja natürlich
unterstützen wir die Demokratien
weltweit das tun wir hier in Europa auch
in einem breiteren Raum als der EU zum
Beispiel im Europarat in der Ostsee das
ist doch ein selbstverständliches
Engagement wir müssen nur Realist
bleiben und nicht glauben dass wir
Deutsche oder Europäer der gesamten Welt
beibringen wie sie ihre Staatlichkeit zu
organisieren haben und deswegen müssen
wir
solange es anders ist auch mit Staaten
zusammenarbeiten kooperieren die nicht
wie Sie es gerade eben korrekt
formuliert haben voll ausgebildete
demokratische Rechtsstaaten sind wie wir
das hier versuchen zu verwirklichen
Außenpolitik muss mit denen Akteuren
umgehen die es tatsächlich auf der Welt
gibt und da gibt es viele Staaten die
sind nicht so demokratisch organisiert
wie wir mit den haben wir trotzdem
Interessen gleich halten mit denen haben
wir trotzdem gemeinsame gute Ziele und
mit denen muss man zusammenarbeiten es
bleibt ein Ritt auf der Rasierklinge
Markt und Moral gleichermaßen zu
organisieren wenn man Außenpolitik macht
darüber haben wir gesprochen mit dem CDU
CSU stellvertreten Fraktionschef Johann
Wade voll wir danken für das Gespräch
heute Morgen sehr gerne einen schönen
Tag